three months ago on one of the most
dramatic rose ceremony ever on The
Bachelorette Kaitlyn chose Shawn and
Shawn got down on bended knee and
proposed and today I am third-wheeling
it with the engaged couple who are
spilling all of their wedding details I
know you're talking next year wedding
but some kind of details
I won't hire a helicopter and fly over
and take photos or anything April first
are you gonna come
would you ever consider getting married
with the cameras around we've talked
about it I it seems like it would be fun
and everyone can come and be there and
it'd be a big event I think if we did do
that we'd probably have a little
intimate wedding after there's a
reputation out there for reality couples
and the majority of the public is quite
pessimistic and they like to say oh they
never work what do you say to those
people we say to them your relationship
might not work either but we don't focus
on that after watching their love
blossom on The Bachelorette it's clear
Kaitlyn and Shawn are a perfect match
but just how ants think are they we put
them to the test at the skanda knob spa
and Whistler welcome to the nearlywed
game' the loser does not get to go into
the beautiful hot tub right there but
rather that's frigid cold shower you
better lose oh okay here we go
what does Shawn think is his best
physical asset what is the first concert
the two of you went to together where is
the craziest place you two have made
whoopee let's see it sleeping we're
watching a movie we're cuddling it
happened you can see the full game on ET
canada.com but spoiler alert Shawn loses
yeah which means we're all winners
but after the cold shower the couple
heat things up in the hot tub well Aaron
spend some quality time alone yeah until
she hijacks their romantic date
okay so first comes the wedding then
comes baby how many like more excited
for babies but after what we disagree on
this one now because I want four it's
crazy he wants five you guys better get
started
I know I'll see you later